Film Courage: What is a high concept idea?
Corey Mandell, Screenwriter and Screenwriting
Instructor:I'll try to answer it but I actually
think it's a total mistake to think that way.
What I was taught and I think what most people
are taught is a high concept is bigger bigger is
better and a high concept is is a concept that's
so exciting that people are going to want to
buy this not they don't even need to see the
characters or the script just that concept is
great and a classic example people will give is
Jaws which was huge Blockbuster movie or people
talk about breaking bad look there's a lot of
different people out there everyone has their
opinion and different people resonate with you
I personally will ignore anyone who says that
and I will suspect they've never had a career
as a writer I've sold a lot of pitches I've helped
writers sell pitches first off here's the concept
of Jaws and just pretend Jaws didn't exist and I
came in and you're an executive and here I pitch
at you all right so there's a shark and it's like
killing people and these three guys get on a boat
and they got to go kill the shark are you like oh
my God that's the best idea ever I that is just
a no I mean Jaws was hugely successful so they
use it as an example but like that concept it's
an interesting concept but like or Breaking
Bad that's such a great concept people would
buy it in the room well that's really I think
interesting information of Vin Gilligan because
he pitched that everywhere in town for four years
and everyone passed so if that's such a high
concept that everyone would buy it that's really
interesting so here's the thing bigger is not
better this is writers torture themselves oh it's
this love story but I've got a meteor coming to
crash like whoa whoa whoa whoa you don't want to
go bigger you want to go deeper so you want to go
deeper and and you really want to figure out what
is most interesting about your concept and how do
you make it more interesting and how do you make
it more interesting and I'll give you an example
just because it's top of head not that so there's
a show that some of you may know some of you may
not know on Apple TV and it's called Slow Horses
and it is a British like thriller and so you've
probably heard of MI5 which is like the CIA like
think about MI5 in London it's like very sleek
sophisticated computers people are well-dressed
and it is like the top spies okay well in London
they have other part they have other departments
and one of them is called slow or slow horse which
they call slow horse and slow horse is the place
you're sent if you really messed up and they want
to punish you it is like the reject loser spy
place to go to and so if you want to be a spy you
want to be an MI5 maybe you were an MI5 and if you
did something terribly wrong you get reassigned
to SL horse or slow horse and you wouldn't want
anyone to know that because you'd be the laughing
stock of the Spy community and once you go to slow
horses there's only one thing you want to do which
is find your way out and back to MI5 only there
you don't it's hell you don't leave hell if you
get if you get sent to slow horses it's terrible
and Gary Oldman is the lead and he plays a guy who
was a James Bond type super spy and he now runs
slow horses which is a really interesting question
like why did he get this worst job ever and I'm
not going to answer that for those of you want
to go watch the show you do eventually find the
reason so this is now you think about this this
could be the beginnings of a concept for comedy
it could be a straight thriller drama you could
actually go a lot of ways with this so this is
a it's a thriller with a little bit of humor
but it's not it's not played for laughs this is
not the bad news bearers of spies okay so now if
you're developing this this is an interesting
idea I think you walk in like you've heard of
MI5 you've heard of the CIA did that there's slow
horses you talk about that and then you talk about
these characters and what they did to get there
and of course some of them deserved it and others
of them just insulted the wrong person's wife
accidentally and now out of spite and so they
have their stories and they want to get out of
there but they can't and what do they do is they
get assigned like the parking management jobs
right like so if there's a potential terrorist
MI5 is going to trail the person and do all this
stuff and slow horses is literally doing traffic
control I mean they do the most menial horrible
things okay not horrible but just meaning boring
stuff well now you're like okay this it's a great
idea but as a concept what are we watching we we
in and week out we're going to watch these people
do traffic control I think that's going to get
pretty boring so you start thinking what could
be a case that they have to do that's going to
be really interesting of course you also got to
figure out why would they get that case that's
part of a writer you got to figure that out and so
you think well let's let's find them having to go
up against a really strong adversary the the KGB
or the Chinese intelligence or the CIA or mad and
you'd be like yeah here are these people and by
the way this is part of the fun of the show when
we see MI5 it's like everyone's beautiful suits
and clothing super high-tech computers they all
drive or are chauffeured in these bulletproof
black SUVs slow horses is this like decrepit
little building with no air conditioning there's
one computer I mean they they also drive their own
cars and it's these little I mean it's just like
this pathetic little operation now if they have
to go against the KGB wow like the there no way
they're going to be able to do that and if there's
real stakes and that could be a really cool
concept but you got to go deeper you got to say
what would be even more interesting would the CIA
be more interesting in the KGB or mad or or MI5
what if they're what if the adversary is MI5
these people who are MI5 got kicked out and
they got nothing what if they got to go against
MI5 what if MI5 is doing something very illegal
and dangerous and slow horses figures it out
and now they got to go undercover and out spy
outsmart these people that's a concept that
you could sell so is that bigger no it's more
interesting that's how you heighten and go
deeper you take what is interesting and you
keep asking methodical questions to make it as
interesting as possible and that very much can
be the difference between people are interested
in you and people buying your work and hiring
you I was taught how to do this by a producer
I never would have sold Metropolis to Ridley
Scott had I not known how to heighten that
was Metropolis high concept it was heightened
concept I don't believe in high concept high
concept is bigger is better now bigger isn't
better what we want is impactful we want to make
something interesting and make it as interesting
as possible and instead of going bigger and high
by the way something that always frustrates me
you talk to anyone who believes in high concept
and you say define it they can't or they'll give
you a definition that makes no sense they'll say
well it's a concept that when people it they want
to buy it oh well that's really helpful after
the fact that's a toy that's not going to help
anybody so I don't believe in high concept I think
that's a trap I believe in heightened concepts.